fermé depuis 2015 est détruite en juin
le centre aqualudique caste alias verra
le jour à maurepas au printemps 2022
après quatre ans de négociations les
communes de maurepas elancourt ont
approuvé le projet définitif de la
piscine qui sera porté par eiffage et
wimdu on a vraiment choisi un candidat
qui est eiffage le constructeur et qui
va exploiter l'équipement avec
l'entreprise récréa swing swing doux
pendant 25 ans sur à maurepas et l'idée
c'est de proposer un équipement qui
conviennent à toutes les générations
que ce soit des bébés jusqu'aux seniors
et en passant par l'apprentissage
scolaire et les clubs sportifs
construit au même endroit le centre
aqualudique accueillera cinq bassins en
inox avec différents espaces bien-être
sportif aqualand un projet à coût total
de 24 millions d'euros financés par le
département la région les deux communes
mais aussi des participations publiques
une grande force aussi dans le projet
c'est que le concessionnaire aura une
obligation d'entretien et de
renouvellement du bâtiment et des
équipements
le concessionnaire art l'obligation tous
les ans d'investir au moins trois cent
mille euros pour entretenir le bâtiment
un équipement qui devra respecter
l'environnement par son architecture et
par les matériaux choisis la pose de la
première pierre est prévue en octobre
2020 pour une ouverture en avril 2022